[Musique]
soir à tous alors ans huissier de
justice vous savez c'est plutôt huissier
de justice parce que c'est une
profession qu'on choisit pas par plus
tôt par opportunité que par vocation je
vous le dis tout de suite
donc je suis un avocat qui a mal tourné
voiliers mais je me rattrape puisque jeu
au sein du rotary j'essaie de faire de
bonnes actions
alors ok aucun homme ne peut vivre sans
idéal cette phrase c'est le grand
cervantes qu'il écrivait fin du xvième
siècle dans une période qui était
extrêmement trou
or espagnol ce grand cervantes qui a
écrit le premier roman de la littérature
mondiale don quichotte de la mancha cet
homme ce chevalier qui part à la
recherche d'un idéal impossible à
atteindre qui rentre chez lui un peu
fourbus dans cette salle je pense que
nous les humains les homo sapiens que
nous sommes nous ne nous sommes tous un
petit peu des don quichotte puisque nous
avons tous c'est ce qui caractérise le
caractérise
nous avons tous un idéal caché au fond
de nous mêmes et c'est ce qui nous fait
traverser la vie depuis notre naissance
jusqu'à notre mort c'est ce qui fait la
différence avec les grands singes qui
eux leur sérieux leur suffit de s'amuser
de se reproduire de manger de dormir
nous il nous faut un plus c'est cet
idéal qui polaris devait avoir en 1950
il a créé le premier club rotarien
chicago savoir je vous fais un rapide
portrait de chicago à l'époque
vous imaginez un cappone les
incorruptibles ce genre de choses si
nous étions au début de l'ère
industrielle pré industrielle américaine
et il y avait des millions d'immigrés
qui venaient d'europe cet hymne est pas
d'afrique cela ils venaient d'europe
c'était c'était des gens comme nous qui
venaient d'italie qui venait d'ukraine
qui venait de pologne qui venait de
d'irlande et qui venait développer cet
idéal qu'ils ont font de même c'est à
dire chasser la misère et faire fortune
au nouveau monde
c'était leur idéal et il arrivait bien
entendu dans un pays qui était en pleine
construction où il y avait l'anarchie la
plus totale où les gens étaient
totalement exploité y avait pas de
règlement sur le travail avait pas de
règlement de syndicats bien entendu
aucune protection il y avait déjà
peut-être la mafia à chicago qui
exploité de manière éhontée
ces personnes de tel point que il ça
arrive et qui traînait dans les rues ou
dans des camps et puis il ne travaillait
il travaillait pour un bol
un bol une soupe uniquement pour manger
la plupart du temps et polaris qui était
un avocat célèbre bien réputée riche
ashiq à chicago il a réuni ses clients
et il a dit ça peut plus durer cette
situation peut plus durer il faut créer
une éthique professionnelle une éthique
une véritable éthique humaniste
on peut pas continuer de supporter de
vivre nous dans la dans la richesse et
de voir ces gens dentelle et à exploiter
complètement
il développe ce concept concept des
idées humanik de l'éthique humaniste que
stefan zweig le grand stéphane ce fait
que vous ne connaissez décrit comme le
cosmopolitisme cosmopolitisme humaniste
c'est dur à dire cosmopolitisme
humaniste qui veut dire quoi c'est une
règle très simple qui maintenant et
passe partout
mais à l'époque c'était largement en
avance sur la société ça veut dire que
les hommes sont tous frères et il doit
s'entraider plutôt que ce exploiter bon
c'est facile à dire
il fallait le mettre en pratique il a
établi une éthique professionnelle avec
ses clients ils ont créé ce club avec
toutes les personnes influentes de la
ville et rapidement comme ses idées
étaient largement attendues par la
société qui se développer aux états unis
toutes les villes des états unis ont
réussi à créer très rapidement comme une
vague des clubs également rotariens sur
le même principe on en est venu à l'idée
était tellement bonne a cédé sa
traverser l'atlantique c'est venu en
europe à toulon nous avons eu en 1926 un
premier club rotarien alors bien entendu
ses idées elles ont fait leur chemin
ces idées maintenant elles ont triomphé
en france on n'aime pas tellement 10 rue
mes idées humanistes on préfère dire les
valeurs républicaines ou des choses
comme ça c'est notre spécificité
française mais dans le monde entier on
parle idées humanistes alors
ces idées maintenant elles ont triomphé
alors est-ce que le rotary est ce que
les clubs rotariens ne sont pas dépassés
compte tenu que ces idées ont triomphé à
quoi ça sert qu'on continue de se réunir
et bien si elles si elles sont partout
ses idées dans la dans la vous rouvrirez
un journal la télévision vous parle
toujours de ses idées on se gargarise un
peu d'ailleurs avec ses idées en
permanence elles sont loin d'être
appliquée dans le monde 1 certes le
rotary est un peu partout il ya que la
corée du nord où il n'y a pas de clubs
rotariens mai mais elles sont loin
d'appliquer alors cette cette démarche
spéculative des clubs avec une certaine
élite avec des professionnels qui
réfléchissaient pour diffuser ses idées
maintenant elle doit passer sur de
l'opérationnel devenir les rotariens
doit venir opérationnel pour mettre en
pratique sur le terrain concrètement ces
idées c'est pour ça que les clubs
maintenant essayer de faire des actions
sur le terrain alors la société évolue
on a les réseaux sociaux on a maintenant
cessé les enjeux et mutations de thèmes
de ce soir qui est très important
qu'est ce que le rotary sera dans 50 ans
alors la chance qu'on a au rotary très
tôt on a trouvé un concept qui est assez
novateur et en france très original à
savoir c'est septembre où notre symbole
c'est cette roue vous l'avez pas là mais
la roue du rotary vous la connaissez tu
es une roue crantée et qui a été
choisi comme symbole au démarrage le but
de ces de dire hérodote bien avant la
création du rotary hérodote vous
connaissez disait la roue c'est un des
plus beaux symboles créée par l'homme
pourquoi parce que ça permet celui qui
est en bas un moment donné de se
retrouver en haut et c'est le principe
des clubs rotariens
c'est à dire que nous sommes un grand
mouvement mondial qui changent de
président chaque année de gouverneur
chaque année et de président de club
chaque année c'est à dire
qu'automatiquement rentrant un club
rotarien vous serez président à un
moment ou un autre
obligé de vous avec l'âge et le rotary
va être exigeant avec vous et vous à
vous demander de prendre des
responsabilités à un moment donné et ça
évite de rester
pourquoi ça parce que le rotary
privilégie toujours l'action à la
fonction et ça c'est une règle de base
très importante pour être efficace alors
bien entendu chaque président change
chaque année et prend des thèmes
nouveaux et tous ces thèmes prix mis
bout à bout depuis 19 ans ça représente
un petit peu une bible humaniste des
bonnes idées des bonnes pratiques
humaniste entre en entrant entre les
hommes cette année c'est soyons
l'inspiration
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire soyons
l'inspiration pour des rotariens
ça veut dire que ce monde qui change
le rotary doit se transformer mais
comment se transformer ne sommes pas une
multinationale
nous sommes une organisation non
gouvernementale avec des bénévoles est
dans un mouvement associatif
le résultat c'est quoi c'est que soyons
l'inspiration dans une multinationale on
réunira un comité d'experts et de
manière verticale on dirait voilà à la
base faut que vous appliquez ça veut pas
dire c'est ce qui se passerait dans une
banque par exemple nous on peut pas
faire comme ça les gens sont bénévoles
on peut pas leur imposer leur donner des
ordres
quand vous êtes rotariens vous donne pas
d ordre c'est vous qui choisissez de
faire une action
donc on demande rotariens de base dans
tous les clubs du monde d'être
l'inspiration de leurs propres de leurs
propres bus transformation de leur
propre mouvement
alors c'est pas ça a été ça a été soyons
l'inspiration ceux qui ont peut-être vu
le film invictus avec nelson mandela
s'est inspiré ce slogan est inspiré de
ce film nelson mandela quand il a pris
les rênes de l'afrique du sud le pays
est au bord de la guerre civile et à ce
moment là
mais nelson mandela a convoqué le leader
de l'équipe des springboks ce qui était
une équipe de rugby blanc qui était
relativement pro-apartheid ce qui avait
été d'abord ni d'ailleurs du rugby
mondial à cause de ça et le capitaine
françois pinard il va le voir et il ya
cette scène dans invictus que vous avez
peut-être vu ils pensent qu'on va lui
dire que les springboks vont être
supprimés mandela va supprimer les
springboks c'est pas du tout nelson
mandela lui dit vous et moi nous allons
et nous avons l'inspiration pour nos
peuples pour développer l'afrique du sud
dans 50 ans et moi je vais mettre le
maillot des springboks celle-ci mandela
et vous allez gagner la coupe du monde
et c6 qui sait ce qui s'est passé alors
bien entendu nous ne sommes pas tous les
rotariens ça serait prétentieux de dire
des petits nelson mandela il y en a
qu'un le grand résonne mais pour ça le
président international dans ce slogan
nous donne 4 thème principal a développé
premier thème l'image publique du rotary
je vous pose la question ceux qui
connaissent pas je suis sûr que dans
votre esprit vous allez dire c'est un
club de notables ou de bourgeois qui se
réunissent et puis peut-être à la fin
ils font un chèque c'est bien pour se
donner une bonne conscience
beaucoup de gens pensent ça en france
malheureusement on n'a pas une très très
bonne image qui n'est pas forcément
celle qui a dans d'autres pays
pourquoi parce qu'on ne communique pas
et on est dans une société de
communication il faut donner de l'argent
aux communicants si on donne pas de
l'argent communicants on ne passe pas
bien moi je vous donne un exemple je
suis ici de justice pendant des années
dans des listings salle profession un
jour j'ai rencontré communiquant à paris
comme je suis vice président d'un
syndicat
il m'a dit mais parce que vous
communiquez pas on a fait une campagne
de pub s'est passé à la télévision que
les petits spots la 20 heures le soir on
a appris de l'argent à tous les
huissiers et bien c'était parfait
maintenant on est une profession utile
parce qu'on a dit on est passé par les
communicants
qui donne les clés malheureusement mais
nous aurons tahri on récupère de
l'argent dans des actions qui sont
difficiles à avoir
est-ce que cet argent on doit leur
distribuer dans à des communicants
professionnels et aux lieux plutôt de
lui donner dans des actions de bénévolat
ou de bienveillance pour des gens qui en
ont besoin
c'est une question deuxième point les
jeunes professionnels on a eu on a eu
des pères des problèmes avec les jeunes
professionnels parce que pendant
longtemps le rotary ou là y compris
quand c'est à chicago dans ces années
terribles on prenait les meilleurs de
chaque profession ce qu'étaient les top
du top de chaque confession
parce qu'on pensait qu'ils s'étaient des
esprits à l'époque éclairé dans une
société qui ne l'étaient pas maintenant
tous assez c'est ça c'est terminé
maintenant tout le monde a admis ses
idées tout le monde évolue et tout le
monde a envie d'aider son prochain
beaucoup tout au moins sont ouverts et
on est resté sur ce système élitiste qui
n'est pas très bon et on n'a pas pris
ces jeunes professionnels qui auraient
pu rentrer dans nos clubs et prendre et
se servir du réseau pour développer
leurs activités
malheureusement d'autres la nature ayant
horreur du vide d'autres organismes
comme des clubs business ont capté ces
jeunes professionnels et souvent ils
sont déçus parce que là on a aucune
éthique professionnelle on y va
uniquement pour faire du fric et du
business et donc on n'a pas tout le côté
éthique du rotary le troisième point
c'est la fondation rotary
on est dans une société mondialisée
maintenant quand il se passe une
catastrophe au japon comme beaucoup
shima toute la terre et sensibiliser et
tout le monde doit réagir et donc les
petites actions qui était fait dans
chaque club dans chaque ville c'était
très bien c'était très utile
c'était à une époque c'était en 1905
maintenant on est dans la mondialisation
avec avec ses enjeux et ses mutations
qui sont le thème
il faut réagir vite et avoir un bras
armé pour agir et ça c'est la fondation
rotary qui a été créée après la guerre
qui est une des plus grandes fondations
au monde en capitalisation et qui a un
partenariat d'ailleurs pour montrer
qu'elle est très efficace
elle est classée chaque année comme la
meilleure fondation par les organismes
américains
qui dépensent le moins le moins de frais
de gestion par rapport aux dons qui est
donnée et elle est en partenariat avec
la fondation de bill et limoux et
melinda gates qui pour un le rotary
donne 10 $ et et bill gates donne 10 $
vous imaginer que si bill gates passe
enfin un partenariat avec la fondation
rotary c'est que c'est du sérieux
le dernier point ce sont les effectifs
on est dans une société très compliqué
très complexes ou maintenant le rotary
dans 19 cents il jongle est sûre cet
esprit de club
vous savez cet esprit de club qui qui
faisait que les angles les aristocrates
anglais avaient développé dans les
années 1900 ça leur permet aux anglo
saxons de dominer le monde et
malheureusement c'est ça touche à sa fin
parce que maintenant avec les nouvelles
technologies les réseaux sociaux les
jeunes qui sont toujours intéressés à
faire le bien est intéressé par luminy
et d'humanité maintenant ils veulent de
l'instantané immédiate et donc on a des
problèmes d'effectif on a des problèmes
d'effectifs importants de moins en moins
de jeunes veulent sans qu'ils veulent
bien venir faire des actions ils veulent
bien de venir travailler
mais rentré dans un club avec les
contraintes d'un club de se voir une ou
deux fois par mois le soir
travailler c'est compliqué ils préfèrent
avoir leurs smartphones et immédiatement
regardez où ils en sont alors c'est pour
ça que le rotary travail sur la
flexibilité
alors la flexibilité de mon france on
n'aime pas ça tout de suite on l'associé
aulas l'emploi au cdi hausse et au
contrat de travail ce genre de choses la
flexibilité au rotary on est en train
d'y travailler c'est pour bientôt
on n'aurait pas besoin de rentrer dans
un club vous pourrez immédiatement
télécharger une application du rotary
qui va vous donner la liste de toutes
les actions mondiales or faite par le
rotary la lutte contre l'éradication de
la poliomyélite par exemple des
problèmes en afrique dos d
préparer et payer des études aux
etats-unis pour dés les réducteurs de
conflits réduire les conflits dans les
pays ou qui sont en guerre on prend des
jeunes qu'on envoie aux états unis dans
les plus grandes universités payé par le
rotary pour les renvoyer ensuite dans
leur pays
voilà tout tous ces éléments et bien
c'est pour ces pour essayer de faire que
les jeunes s'intéressent au rotary
puisse faire des actions dont qui
téléchargeront ils seront immédiatement
informé il ya une réunion à tel endroit
vous pouvez faire un don à tel endroit
où il ya une conférence à tel endroit
maintenant vous pouvez être volontaire
pour aller dans tel pays payé par le
rotary pour faire des actions précises
de mettre un puits ou vérifier que
l'argent est bien dépensé dans tel pays
voilà voilà l'avenir du rotary au
travers de la flexibilité
alors bien entendu je vais terminer si
vous voulez un pour vous dire de revenir
vers vers cervantes si vous voulez
servant don quichotte partait un peu se
battre contre des moulins à vent c'était
un idéal complètement désuet le rotary
c'est pas un idéal des jouets c'est une
action concrète on fait des actions
parfaitement concrètes et je peux même
vous dire que pour citer le philosophe
préféré de notre président actuel
paraît-il qui schopenhauer qui disait la
richesse c'est comme l'eau de mer plus
on en boit plus on a soif et bien je
peux vous dire que les actions du rotary
quand vous en faites
plus vous en faites que vous avez envie
d'en faire donc
engagez-vous rotary et vous verrez vous
ne le regretterez pas je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]